Speaker 1: Another item the Democrats are
trying to get done here falls on the shoulder,
the shoulders, the mighty shoulders of Elizabeth
Warren.
Another New York Times article, Elizabeth
Warren will propose a minimum tax on the nation's
richest companies.
Now, this comes on the heels of reporting
from several years ago where there were over
90 companies of the largest corporations in
America that paid zero income tax.
Zero, John Deere zero, Amazon zero.
This falls this comes on the heels of the
reporting from just a few months ago from
ProPublica of all of the billionaires who
didn't pay any tax, Elon Musk, Jeff Bezos,
Warren Buffett, perennial liberal advocate
for for raising taxes on the wealthy.
He didn't pay very much.
Reading from this article, Senator Elizabeth
Warren of Massachusetts and her allies will
propose a minimum tax on the profits of the
nation's richest companies regardless of what
they say they owe the government.
As part of the Democrats, three point five
trillion dollar economic and social policy
package.
Miss Warren's so-called real corporate profits
tax was a key part of her presidential campaign,
and she has enlisted Senator Angus King, the
Maine Independent, to help press her case
that profitable companies should be taxed
regardless of loopholes and maneuvers that
have allowed many of them to avoid federal
corporate income taxes altogether.
What does it say about our system, the morality
of our system?
That we demonize those who are getting ready
to be evicted from their houses, we demonize
the housing.
And we lift up as paragons as examples of
how to live billionaires who who enjoy outrageous
wealth, unimaginable wealth, who pay nothing
into the system, instead, they live off loans
using stock as collateral, and then that loan
ends up being a liability that they actually
can get a tax break from.
It is immoral.
I'm not necessarily opposed.
Two billionaires, I am opposed to a system
that allows them to to exist with impunity.
Continuing on here, the measure would require
the most profitable companies to pay a seven
percent tax on the earnings they report to
investors known as their annual book value
above 100 million.
By taxing the earnings reported to investors,
not to the Internal Revenue Service, Democrats
would be hitting earnings that companies like
to maximize, not the earnings they try hard
to diminish for tax purposes.
And this is what Elizabeth Warren had to say
about this during the presidential campaign.
Joe Biden and I disagreed on some tax policies,
but there was one thing we strongly agreed
on.
Corporations shouldn't be able to tell shareholders
they were making huge profits, then tell the
IRS they made nothing in profits.
Truer words.
When Jeff Bezos and his cadre of billionaire
pals.
Benefit from a system that we have that has
made them what they are.
Of course, there was hard work that went into
it.
I'm not saying that doesn't play a role, but
luck plays and plays an outsized role in the
success of people like this.
It's not just their ingenuity.
There are a million points of data.
That lead to their success, what's what's
the phrase about preparation and lock when
when combined with some nonsense saying.
Fortune favors the well prepared or whatever.
All of that is true, but without luck and
without the sweat and the and the the tears
and the blood and the sacrifice of people
who work for these corporations, they would
have nothing.
And to to enjoy the spoils of everything that
is benefiting them that this country offers
and then to pay zero in tax.
Whether you be a corporation or whether you
be an individual like Jeff Bezos or Elon Musk,
it is immoral, it is reprehensible, and it
needs to be legislated.
Need people on Capitol Hill, elected representatives,
that is, after all, what they do, they represent
us and they need to do more for us.
And not the people who make major payments
to their PACs, major contributions to their
political campaigns, that is what's most important.
We, the people.
Not we, the corporation